barrikaden an der uni in hongkong wollen
protestierende studenten nicht aufgeben
die situation spitzt sich zu kurswechsel
in der nahostpolitik die usa betrachten
den israelischen siedlungsbau im
besetzten westjordanland nicht länger
als illegal entscheidung über leben und
tod dürfen schwer kranke menschen in
extremen notsituationen tödliche
medikamente bekommen
das muss jetzt das
bundesverfassungsgericht klären
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers einen guten abend
hinein geben sie uns 20 minuten wir
geben ihnen den überblick über diesen
nachrichten dienstag kristin otto
steuert nachher den sport beinah mit
zwei fußball themen benennt auch heute
gucken wir am anfang auf hongkong wo die
polizei innerhalb von 24 stunden rund
1000 menschen festgenommen hat und damit
droht eine universität zu stürmen in der
sich demonstranten verschanzt haben die
seit monaten aus sorge um freiheit und
demokratie in hongkong protestieren rund
um die uni spielen sich dramatische
szenen haben stephanie schöneborn mit
mehr nach stundenlanger befragung
verlassen ein paar protestler freiwillig
die universität neben einer anzeige
wegen aufruhr und zehn jahre haft in
kauf 100 weitere protestler nicht
sie suchen andere wege auf einmal
stürzen sich polizisten auf einen der
über das gelände rennt fliehen will er
wird festgenommen
seine familie steht hinter der
absperrung ihre angst ist greifbar
die polizei beschimpft die angehörigen
nennt sie kakerlaken auch der hass ist
altbach ihr habt nicht das recht die
menschen in hongkong kakerlaken zu
nennen ihr habt nicht das recht uns zu
beleidigen nicht in hongkong 600
protestler werden heute auf dem
universitätsgelände abgeführt dass sie
sich freiwillig festnehmen lassen wurde
hart verhandelt so weit es geht haben
die demonstranten juristischen beistand
von freiwilligen
einige sind verletzt nachdem die polizei
vorgestern alle sanitäter festgenommen
hatte gab es in der universität auch
keine ärztliche versorgung mehr und die
regierung kündigt weiteres hartes
vorgehen an eine friedliche lösung gebe
es unter einer bedingung
dieses ziel kann nur unter
uneingeschränkter kooperation der
demonstranten vor allem auch der
randalierer erreicht werden sie müssen
die gewalt einstellen ihre waffen
abgeben es freiwillig heraus kommen und
die anweisung der polizei genauestens
befolgen
das gelände um die universität herum
wird von der polizei strengstens
überwacht und die wiederum steht unter
genauer beobachtung der pavillon connor
und familienangehörigen die sich getraut
haben hier hinzu kommen live nach
hongkong zu ulf röller und guten abend
wie ist die situation im moment an
dieser universität
wir sind nur wenige meter von der
universität entfernt und wie man hier
sehen kann hat die polizei quasi einen
eisernen ring um das universitätsgelände
gemacht keiner kommt rein oder raus wenn
das die polizei nicht will
es herrscht hier eine gespenstische ruhe
es ist keiner mehr auf die straße und
nicht nur weil es nachts um zwei us
sondern weil hier dramatische trust
straßenschlachten stattgefunden haben
wir sehen dass hier noch die ganzen
spuren der schlacht und die trümmer in
der universität sind etwa noch 30
studenten und die platz polizei wartet
ab sie wird wohl nicht stürmen weil sie
kein blutbad will sondern sie weiß dass
diese ständen hüte sind irgendwann raus
kommen und dann nimmt sie sie fest und
gucken wir mal für eine minute auf das
etwas größere bild wie sehr ist in
hongkong geprägt von diesen protesten
beschränkt sich das jetzt auf einzelne
gegenden oder spürt man dass quasi
überall also hongkong ist eine stadt mit
zwei gesichtern es gibt durchaus dieses
lebhaft und fröhliche hongkong dass man
kennt es und cafés offen
die leute sitzen draußen und lachen sie
gehen einkaufen und dann gibt es eben
diese hotspots wo es eben doch massive
demonstrationen gibt und gewalt aber
insgesamt haben natürlich die wochen und
monate der demonstrationen die unruhen
die gewalt ein bisschen die seele dieser
stadt aufgefressen
die bürger haben große angst dass die
internationale anerkennung dieser stadt
verloren geht und sie nur noch als chaos
stadt gesehen wird deswegen wollen viele
noch mal einen großen friedlichen
massenprotest auf die straße bringen
das problem ist die polizei genehmigt
eigentlich gar keine demonstrationen
mehr unseres hongkong in der eigenen
situation gefangen und keiner weiß so
genau wie es weitergehen soll
wichtige hintergründe aus hongkong will
herzlichen dank
für für julian assange den gründer der
enthüllungsplattform wikileaks heute ein
erfolg die justiz in schweden hat das
ermittlungsverfahren wegen
vergewaltigung eingestellt
die vorwürfe gegen ihn seien zwar
glaubwürdig aber nach fast einem
jahrzehnt erinnerten sich die zeugen
nicht mehr genau sagt die
staatsanwaltschaft
der gründer der umstrittenen plattformen
sitzt seit april in großbritannien in
haft
ihm droht weiterhin eine auslieferung an
die usa
dort ist er wegen der veröffentlichung
geheimer dokumente und verstößen gegen
das anti- spionagegesetz angeklagt
in einem entscheidenden punkt der nahost
politik hat die us-regierung jetzt ganz
offiziell ihren kurs gewechselt und
damit bei den palästinensern und den
europäern heftige kritik ausgelöst
und israels regierungschef glücklich
gemacht die israelischen siedlungen im
westjordanland betrachten die usa jetzt
nicht mehr als illegal
und darum geht es seit dem
sechstagekrieg 1967 hält israel das
westjordanland besetzt
heute leben dort mehr als 600.000
israelische siedler zwischen drei
millionen palästinensern
international gilt das bislang als bruch
des völkerrechts für die usa allerdings
sind diese siedlungen jetzt
unproblematisch welche folgen das hat
nicola albrecht berichtet für israels
premier netanjahu hätte es keine
schönere nachricht aus washington geben
können
symbol schwanger verkündet er seine
dankesbotschaft aus dem siedlungsblock
gusch etzion im von israel besetzten
westjordanland
hier stehen wir nun an einem
historischen tag mit einer weiteren
riesigen errungenschaft für den staat
israel an der wir lange gearbeitet haben
die trump administration hat ein
historisches unrecht korrigiert und
steht nun an der seite der wahrheit und
gerechtigkeit
in den augen der palästinenser zeigt die
us-administration nochmals vor allem
aber auf wessen seite sie steht als
vermittler hat washington sich damit in
ihren augen disqualifiziert die
internationale staatengemeinschaft dazu
zwingen die israelische
expansionspolitik zu akzeptieren und die
zerstörung aller grundlagen für frieden
hinzunehmen
mittlerweile leben mehr als 650.000
israelische siedler im westjordanland
für die palästinenser bedeutete dass
kein gleichberechtigtes leben
nebeneinander land wurde ihnen genommen
ständig ist das israelische militär
präsent es soll die siedler schützen und
die palästinenser unter kontrolle halten
die entscheidung der us-regierung zeigt
vor allem eins trump interessiert sich
weder für internationales recht noch
berücksichtigt er bei seinen
entscheidungen menschenrechtsfragen und
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
verliert sich in ihrer kritik daran
immer mehr in hilflosen floskeln frieden
auf basis einer zwei-staaten-lösung wird
so jedenfalls immer weniger
wahrscheinlich
netanyahu allerdings oft von der
entscheidung profitieren er kämpft
gerade um eine weitere amtszeit als
premierminister und jetzt zu einem
anderen krisenherd in der region im iran
tobt eine protestwelle es geht gegen
preiserhöhungen bei benzin und gegen die
regierung dutzende menschen sollen ums
leben gekommen seien sagt das uno
menschenrechtskommissariat es gebe
glaubhafte berichte dass irans
sicherheitskräfte scharfe munition gegen
demonstranten einsetzten
weil staatliche stellen das internet
aber abgeschaltet hätten seien die
berichte schwer zu überprüfen
live nach teheran zu unserem
korrespondenten lück wahl port glück
haben wir überhaupt einen genauen
überblick heute abend welche ausmaße
diese proteste haben und wie viele opfer
es tatsächlich gab
nein die informationskontrolle der
regierung ist sehr dichte und sehr
flächendeckend das internet wurde
abgestellt wir selbst können uns zwar in
der stadt bewegen aber natürlich nicht
im ganzen land und aus dem land kommen
nur sehr spärlich informationen hier in
die hauptstadt eben nur über telefon
sonst geht hier gar nichts aber die
staatlich gelenkte presse selbst hat
zugegeben dass am wochenende annähernd
100.000 menschen in 40 städten auf den
straßen waren es soll mehr als 100
tankstellen banken und leben zerstört
worden sein und eben auch scharf
geschossen worden
da gibt es glaubhafte berichte und
amnesty spricht davon dass die zahl der
toten weit über den amtlichen angaben
liegt möglicherweise über 100 menschen
die bei diesen protesten ums leben
gekommen
mal abgesehen davon dass das internet
nicht funktioniert wie geht denn die
iranische regierung gegen die
protestierenden vor
äußerst hart ich glaube viele iraner
sind selbst überrascht nicht nur vom
ausmaß und der heftigkeit der proteste
am wochenende sondern auch von der
reaktion der behörden die menschen die
wir heute ihren teheran sprechen konnten
wollten jedenfalls nicht mit uns vor der
kamera reden
das hat auch damit zu tun dass die
justiz angekündigt hat gegen die mehr
als 1000 demonstranten die festgenommen
wurden bei den protesten am wochenende
hart vorgehen zu wollen
es gibt eine zeitung hier die als
sprachrohr der hardliner gilt keyhan
heißt die die hat sogar die todesstrafe
gefordert und gesagt das seien alles
saboteure die vom ausland bezahlte und
gelenkt wurden angesichts solcher töne
ist es verständlich dass viele menschen
heute eher vorsicht walten lassen die
proteste abgeebbt haben aber die wut der
bürger über die misswirtschaft und die
tatsache dass die schere zwischen arm
und reich immer weiter auseinandergeht
die app sicher so schnell nicht ab
günstige situation im iran glück vielen
dank diesen bericht live aus teheran
gleich zwölf staats und regierungschefs
aus afrika sind heute in berlin bei der
bundeskanzlerin die einen pakt schmieden
will mit afrika und deutsche unternehmen
motivieren dort mehr zu investieren
die bundesregierung will dabei helfen
merkel sagte aber auch dass zunächst die
rahmenbedingungen in afrika verbessert
werden müssten
dazu gehörten vor allem der kampf gegen
korruption und für mehr rechtssicherheit
zum insolventen reiseveranstalter thomas
cook jetzt da wird die deutsche
konzerntochter zerschlagen einen großen
teil kauft der warenhauskonzern galeria
karstadt kaufhof
er übernimmt 100 sechs der 126
reisebüros nach angaben von thomas cook
würden damit mehr als 500 arbeitsplätze
gerettet
auch für weitere unternehmenstöchter
etwa für bucher reisen und öger tours
gebe es angebote es gibt krankheiten die
sind so grausam dass sie einen umbringen
manche so langsam und so qualvoll dass
die betroffenen freiwillig sterben
wollen
das ist den ausnahmefällen auch erlaubt
entschied das bundesverwaltungsgericht
im märz 2017 das entsprechende
medikament beantragten seitdem 131
todkranke menschen keiner von ihnen
bekam der erlaubnis der stadt blockiert
die patienten verzweifeln ihnen blieb
heute der weg vor gericht christoph
schneider persönlich ist der nach köln
ans verwaltungsgericht gekommen harald
meyer den 49 jährigen der seit 22 jahren
an multipler sklerose leidet geht es
zunehmend schlechter
seit drei jahren ist er auf den
rollstuhl angewiesen kann nur noch den
kopf bewegen keine chancen auf besserung
die probleme werden ja stärker niemals
locker und oder ich krieg auch als man
keine luft mehr und da kriegt man schon
panik und dann will ich das bei ende ja
harald meyer möchte selbst bestimmen
wann und wie sein leben enden soll
beim bundesinstitut für arzneimittel hat
er einen antrag auf eine tödliche dosis
natrium pentobarbital gestellt doch die
behörde lehnt ab wohl auch weil es eine
bitte des bundesgesundheitsministeriums
gibt sämtliche anträge zu versagen
deswegen hat meyer klage beim
verwaltungsgericht köln erhoben und die
siebte kammer urteilt nicht sondern legt
seinen fall jetzt dem
bundesverfassungsgericht vor
das gericht ist der meinung dass man es
schwer kranken personen die sich in
einer existenziellen notlage befinden
nicht verwehren darf ein mittel zur
selbsttötung zu erlangen
das geltende betäubungsmittelgesetz gibt
aber zugleich der behörde keine
möglichkeit eine solche erwerbs
erlaubnis die erforderlich wäre zu
erteilen
deswegen ist das gesetz insoweit
verfassungswidrig das problem für die
kölner richter das
betäubungsmittelgesetz auf dass die
anträge für todbringende medikamente
gestützt werden erlaubt nicht sie zu
diesem zweck herauszugeben
aber ein generelles verbot sei nicht mit
dem grundgesetz vereinbar sagen die
richter
und so müssen die verfassungsrichter an
der widerspruch müsse aufgelöst werden
harald meyer kann diese entscheidung
nachvollziehen
es wird sich was bewegen in dem thema
mit dem gefühl falsch nach hause bis zu
einer entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts werden sicher
noch einige monate vergehen monate lang
haben sie in observierte und jetzt
zugeschlagen in berlin haben ermittler
einen terrorverdächtigen festgenommen
offenbar hatte der 26 jährige syrer vor
bei einem bombenanschlag möglichst viele
menschen zu töten
laut staatsanwaltschaft hatte sich der
mann anleitungen zur herstellung von
sprengstoff und waffen besorgt in
internetforen die dem sogenannten
islamischen staates nahe stehen auch
bauteile und chemikalien für bomben habe
er sich bereits beschafft ganz anderes
thema jetzt brodelt unter uns tief unter
uns und anders als wind und sonne
liefern die tiefen unserer erde immer
energie egal wie das wetter ist
das prinzip ist ganz einfach tausende
meter unter der erdoberfläche herrschen
hohe temperaturen
die geothermie nutzt diese wärme indem
sie das heiße wasser nach oben gepumpt
und dann in energie umwandelt zum heizen
und um strom zu gewinnen
danach wird es zurück in die tiefe
gespült ein prinzip das in deutschland
nur 0,1 prozent der stromerzeugung aus
erneuerbaren energien ausmacht und das
soll sich jetzt ändern wie peter aumer
berichtet grünwald bei münchen schlote
aber keine fabrik hier steht ein
kraftwerk das die energie aus dem
erdinnern holt aus knapp 4000 metern
tiefe kommt 127 grad heißes
thermalwasser wir produzieren wärme aus
geothermie und wir produzieren strom aus
gutem ihren wir können wärme für eine
gemeinde wie grünwald bereitstellen
12.000 einwohner und wir können aus der
überschüssigen energie strom
bereitstellen für größenordnung 20 bis
30.000 menschen
das heißt wir haben hier ein
unglaubliches energiepotenzial aus der
energie die wir aus dem bayerischen
boden holen
37 tiefen geothermie anlagen sind in
deutschland in betrieb 28 in bau oder
planung geothermiebohrungen können zu
gebäudeschäden führen wie in staufen im
breisgau 2007 damals war ein falsches
gestand feld angebohrt worden die
auflagen für bohrgenehmigungen wurden
seitdem verschärft eine studie des
umweltbundesamtes von 2015 sieht keine
unbeherrschbaren risiken für die umwelt
der bundesverband geothermie verweist
auf die besonderen vorteile der erdwärme
geothermie ist eben die einzige
erneuerbare wärme die unbeeinflusst bar
von klima und wie ein fluss ball von
wetter von tag und nacht 24 stunden
vorhanden ist und natürlich auch ein
entsprechend langfristiges reserve hat
die investitionskosten geothermie sind
hoch für grünwald hatte sich gelohnt
35 millionen euro gewinn erwirtschaftet
das kommunale unternehmen jedes jahr
wieder ausgelernt jetzt freue ich mich
auf den sport
ich muss mich auch zweimal fußball heute
in knapp 90 minuten anpfiff zum letzten
auftritt der nationalmannschaft in
diesem jahr gegen nordirland in
frankfurt am main das em ticket ist ja
bereits gelöst bleibt das ziel mit einem
sieg die quali runde als gruppen-erster
vor den niederlanden abzuschließen
toni kroos übernimmt heute die rolle des
kapitäns weil wie von löw geplant manuel
neuer nicht im tor stehen wird sondern
sein herausforderer marc andré ter
stegen
mit einem sieg würde das team platz eins
sichern der bei der gruppen auslosung
für die em noch eine wichtige rolle
spielen kann
erster zu werden am ende ich finde es
immer wir sind wir schön auch wenn wir
uns so oder so qualifizieren aber jetzt
haben wir das spiel haben und dann
müssen wir das auch so annehmen dass wir
dass wir es gewinnen es werden nicht so
viele plätze frei bleiben wie bei den
letzten heimspielen der dfb rechnet mit
40.000 fans das letzte länderspiel des
jahres wird somit ganz ordentlich
besucht sein
eintracht kapitän david abraham bleibt
nach seiner rüden attacke gegen
freiburgs trainer christian streich für
sieben wochen gesperrt so das urteil des
dfb sportgerichts nach dem einspruch der
frankfurter es ist die aufreger szene
des letzten spieltages und sie hat wenig
mit sport zu tun
bodycheck des frankfurters abraham gegen
freiburgs trainer streich anschließenden
rudelbildung und rot für den eintracht
kapitän nachspiel vor einer woche am
grünen tisch abraham gesperrt bis ende
des jahres sein verein protestiert
dagegen heute die bestätigung der sperre
das was oben passiert findet seine
wiederholung an der basis deshalb musste
ein zeichen gesetzt werden als
abschreckungswirkung auch bestätigt drei
spiele sperre für freiburg street wo der
abraham hier ins gesicht greift bilder
von sportlern die nach diesen zehn nicht
als vorbilder tauben ob die harten
sanktionen jetzt für mehr fairplay und
anstand sorgen bleibt abzuwarten
viel unsportliches im sport vielen dank
jetzt gucken aufs wetter das bleibt im
norden und osten meist novembergrau im
westen soll es etwas freundlicher werden
und alle einzelheiten hat gleich gunther
tiersch
der kollege claus kleber hat das heute
journal für sie um 21 45 darin ein
gespräch mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister zur zukunft
der windenergie bei uns morgen 19 uhr
gibt es uns wieder wir würden uns sehr
freuen wenn sie dabei sind in allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einige zuschauer vor uns liegen ruhige
nebeltage zum teil auch mit ein bisschen
sonne aber es kann auch hier und da mal
ein bisschen tröpfeln die temperaturen
ändern sich eigentlich kaum wir haben
höchsttemperaturen von etwa fünf bis
zehn grad hier in mitteleuropa
kalt ist es direkt in russland dort
haben wir weiter im osten temperaturen
von minus zehn bis minus 20 grad
höchsttemperaturen aber diese kälte
kommt zwar noch ein bisschen nach westen
aber nicht nach mitteleuropa wir haben
da noch ein bisschen frost in dieser
nacht hier im westen in den
mittelgebirgen bis minus 5 grad im osten
dagegen bleibt es frostfrei da ziehen
eben noch diese regenwolken vom
erzgebirge langsam hoch bis zur ostsee
im süden und im westen wird es sehr
neblig und es kann sehr glatt werden da
hat es heute ja noch geregnet im westen
ist überführt jetzt in den nächsten
stunden und dann wird spiegelglatt unter
umständen morgen immer noch etwas regen
leichter regen nordöstlich der elbe der
langsam zur ostsee rauszieht sonst
bleibt es ziemlich trübe norddeutschland
nur so am niederrhein kommt die sonne
raus aber dann auch in den
mittelgebirgen und vor allen dingen auch
an den alpen aber zwischendrin an der
donau bleibt es den ganzen tag über
ziemlich niedlich
ja und die temperaturen erreichen wieder
etwa vier bis acht grad die aussichten
dann ruhiges wetter so langsam dreht der
wind aus südost bis ost mal ist es doch
nicht mal auch ziemlich trüb ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen abend und machen
sie's gut